[Musique]
aux états unis on ne parle que de cette
nouvelle bien sûr la mort de george bush
père père de la dynastie des bouches qui
a été 41e un président américain
et c'était peut-être donc au cours des
dernières heures
on le voit d'ailleurs ici au bras de sa
femme barbara qui s'était intel au
printemps dernier alors il avait une
immense feuille de route un seul mandat
comme président américaine mais il a été
également vice président américain
pendant huit années son mandat qui a été
fort marquée par la politique
internationale avec la guerre du golfe
notamment
alors ce matin mais on devait parler du
g20 on va en parler nécessairement bien
sûr mais ça mais ressort le professeur
en histoire des relations
internationales à l'université de
montréal est avec moi ce matin bonjour
bonjour alors parlons tout d'abord du
legs de george bush comme 41e président
des états unis
il faut d'abord dire que george bush est
un parfait représentant de l'élite
américaine de l'élite de la côte est
c'est à dire est très liée aux affaires
ses parents sont des banquiers ou des
investisseurs à wall street
il est étudiant à yale donc ivy league
c'est le parcours normal de l'élite
américaine en économie effectivement
mais ensuite ils passent aux affaires
lui même et fait fortune dans le pétrole
au texas
c'est l'époque donc du pétrole très très
très en forme et il devient donc un
homme d'affaires très qu'il a réussi
bien dans ce monde là il cherche aussi à
retourner à entrer en politique
il sait se faire élire sénateur ne
réussit pas aux enfers la vérité son
père était sénateur effectivement c'est
une dynastie donc acquis et kim kim et
ou qui mêle les affaires et la politique
allait essayer de faire élire il n'a y
pas et finit pas donc pas ses parts dans
la diplomatie ou des questions
internationales
ddd et amis d'abord il devient
ambassadeur aux nations unies
ensuite représentant en chine est
ensuite directeur de la cia donc très
lié à l'establishment tout ce qui est à
faire de sécurité à faire de diplomatie
internationale et l'heure était
également à la chambre des représentants
pendant quelques années pour le parti
républicain était représentant
effectivement donc il ya ilahi l'aï le
lien ou le il est odieux à la charnière
entre des affaires et la politique mais
il devient véritablement personnage
lorsqu'il devient vice président avec
avec
colistier de regragui et président
lui-même à partir de 1988
donc je pense qu'il devient président
lorsqu'il accède à la maison blanche
c'était la fin de la guerre froide
également un modèle qui va avoir été
marquée par la guerre du golfe
vous nous parler des quatre années de
son unique mandat comprise
effectivement il a profité du de la
désintégration du bloc soviétique et la
fin de du rival aux états unis le moon
soo ray aux états unis il devenait
désormais la puissance hégémonique
d'appui là l'unique superpuissance et en
a profité pour faire cette guerre du
golfe contre l'irak et surtout montrer
au monde les merveilles de l'armement
america c'est une guerre télévisé
c'est une guerre ou cnn apparaît tous
les jours où il ya en voie de la gare en
continu daguerre minute par minute
et l on montre alors toute la
quincaillerie militaire américaine pour
impressionner le monde et faire
comprendre aux autres votre tour
pourrait arriver si vous faites comme
gac l'italie pourrait vous vous vous
attaquer donc c'est une manière de
marquer d'arrivée de l'hégémonie
américaine dans le monde et d'en
profiter
il est le président donkey
qui représente l'avènement de l'époque
du lugner de l'unilatéralisme américain
du monde unipolaire et c'est sa marque
à ce moment là c'est le moment où il
veut se démarquer de ses prédécesseurs
regardez laissé par la suite la
politique intérieure c'est vraiment
intéressé plus à l'extérieur à ces
conflits mondiaux et donc il va perdre
en 1992 contre bill clinton alors
j'aimerais quand même qu'on glisse un
mot sur le g20 oui c'était effectivement
c'était le sujet bien que j'aie sa
chasse un autre dans le bras les mots de
finale
parce que dans la chambre est
actuellement au g20 et il a cette
rencontre avec la chine
aujourd'hui ça va éclipser un peu tout
le reste l'actuel tout à fait alors
trompeta personnage tout à fait
différent de leur couche bush qui était
le sortie l'élite tout posé est bien
bien bien bien bien entraîné trempez
plutôt à lundi surtout d'année
d'individus impulsif qui agit par
instants et trempent cherche la avoir
des avantages avoir des avantages dans
le commerce international dans
l'économie internationale que le
multilatéralisme ne donne plus aux états
unis
bush aura été un multilatéraliste
craintes ne l'est pas kramp essaie donc
de remettre en question les multiples ce
qui remet en question le débat parce que
le g20 est basée sur le multilatéralisme
il est là comme un cheveu dans la soupe
en train de chez de modifier les règles
du jeu alors est ce que ça va changer
grand chose on le grêlé des g20 ne sont
pas ou les rencontres au sommet ne sont
pas des lieux de décisions ce sont des
lieux où l'on se rencontre où l'on peut
avoir la température ou l'atmosphère
internationale
mais ce n'est pas un endroit où l'on
décide ça nous permettra donc de jauger
un peu la situation
mais on peut pas s'attendre à des
décisions
on va on va percevoir l'état décidé
d'aider d'esprit on va prendre la
température de cette guerre commerciale
que se livrent les états unis et la
chine
on va également voir comment sera
accueillie bon ça a déjà été fait par
vladimir poutine également par un menu
le maquereau mais le prince héritier de
l'arabie saoudite
mohamed ben salman pour avoir quelques
statues il conserve ou et là sur la
scène internationale vous allez regarder
ça certes effectivement et il fait son
coming-out essaie de se prouver compris
qu'il est qu'il est toujours acceptés
sur la scène internationale en fait il
de sera il faut pas se faire d'illusions
il le sera parce que les rappeurs avec
l'arabie saoudite sont des rapports
économiques très sérieux et très très
très très dense des rapports politiques
que géostratégique sorte qu' il va être
là il va accepter même si les pays
occidentaux nous ont pas multiplier les
sympathies visible à son égard se
déclare très sensible évidemment ce très
sensible vis-à-vis de leurs opinions
publiques
mais vis-à-vis de leurs intérêts ils
vont rester en rapport avec la vie sauve
il n'aura pas de sanction il ne sera pas
l'arabie saudite ne sera pas mise au ban
des nations
faut pas se faire d'illusions c'est
simplement une une tempête qu'on espère
voir passer du côté occidental et merci
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin ça fait plaisir ça y est on va